I guarantee you that reason published on
a campus would be defunded and that
you'd be up on harassment charges every
other week hi I'm Nicholas P for recent
TV and today we're talking with Alan
Charles Coors who is the Henry Charles
Lee professor of history at University
of Pennsylvania the co-founder of fire
the foundation for individual rights in
education and one of the great
historians of the Enlightenment in fact
the editor of the Oxford encyclopedia of
the Enlightenment Alan thanks for
talking with us my privilege let's talk
about higher education free speech
related issues let's start with the
higher education bubble people like
Glenn Reynolds a law professor runs
insta pundit calm has written a book
about the higher education bubble other
observers look at this there has been a
pronounced increase in the costs of
college the need or perceived need for a
college education for a for a diploma is
there a higher education bubble and if
so what do you think its causes and its
outcomes are gonna be when you get a
subsidized tuition universities will
raise it and in terms of all the debate
about costs there's no competition in
their subsidy and a child could figure
out what's likely to happen
you've been at Penn since 68 in 1968
most jobs even things like being a
journalist say would not require a
college degree necessarily so what
happened that we have to go to college
now it seems to me as society and the
economy became more complex in the
skills it demanded universities were in
a unique position they're the only
institution in society allowed to sort
people out by IQ and the ability to
complete complex tasks that is why the
corporation's recruit there that's why
the high paying firms recruit there no
firm hires from a university thinking
maybe this kid studied post-modernism or
oh look this guy did sociology of gender
that is not why University is higher if
anything excuse me why business is
higher if anything they do it despite
that so the universities are essentially
whatever other pretensions they might
have they're essentially doing a first
cut of the applicant pool for major
corporations yes and I think it's more
than a first cut in the sense of if you
graduate from a flagship university
you've passed the first cut and been
given a major push towards success and
parents do not invest in the quality of
a kids education they invest and it's a
rational choice they invest in the value
of the degree to their children what
kind of options does it open up what is
the role of the humanities in higher
education and you know where does it
need to go to regain some sense of
legitimacy recognizing if the humanities
have been under attack from at least a
moment that they became recognized as
the humanities but how do you defend
this one I think you have to make a
fundamental distinction between the
humanities in their current form as they
exist with political litmus tests in
hiring and with partisan political
agendas agendas often in research in
programs in research and in teaching and
in the nature of okay we'll talk a
little bit about that because and you're
not saying here that people who study or
research or analyze what might be called
minor histories or you know seemingly
irrelevant people yeah I mean you're
you're not making a kind of grandiose
claim that we should only be studying
history and literature and art from
above or or passing on the received
wisdom of our of our fourth no far from
it and I have always voted the higher
people who think radically different
from myself who are asking question
that I wouldn't ask the problem is that
a lot of those people wish to clone
themselves run their department and see
voices that are dissident to their own
orthodoxies as uncle ezel rather than as
an interesting addition or mix in the
debate but let's go back to your main
point not what's happened to certain
fields in the humanities but the value
of the humanities in general run what I
note and I've been teaching at the
University of Pennsylvania since 1968 is
students of mine who take demanding
courses in the humanities they master
whatever is out there next all they have
to do is get a foot in the door and
their intelligence their ability to
think critically their ability to
analyze other people's perspectives
their ability to read difficult and
complex tests texts their their openness
to understanding how different people
think let them write their own tickets
so it's very common for me to have
students whose parents they tell me or
forever saying for them how could you
study intellectual history right in
college what is that going to get you
well what it gets them is a door inside
of what used to be Boston Consulting
where they quickly stand out in terms of
their intelligence or if they go into
the nonprofit world they quickly stay
and that is because I mean in a
humanities you know in a well-executed
humanities course of study you are being
more synthetic in terms of pulling
different things together you situate
things in particular cultural context
historical economic literary what I mean
the the double benefit is of
simultaneously being more synthetic in
exactly the way you've described and
more analytic and the ability to combine
those to read things in context to read
things looking for the culture and the
society and the meanings out of which
they've emerged this deepens
sharpens the mind but if you are taking
a course the goal of which is to make
you understand that you have false
consciousness that you don't understand
the way in which America has brainwashed
and mystified your mind which has given
us and I believe it's an increasing
phenomenon with each passing year a
faculty that thinks of its primary goal
as the demystification of students who
have been brainwashed and given false
consciousness by consumer capitalist
America that is not a local election
value though you might still engage some
interesting texts in the course of that
and and that also then I mean
essentially in that sense while there
demystifying the humanities or power
relations they're also ultimately
devaluing what they're studying well
that's that's exactly right and they are
contributing to the very crisis of the
humanities that they are bemoaning when
I was an undergraduate at Princeton and
so this would have been in the early
sixties I I was a history major took a
ton of literature courses classics
courses what the surveys tell me and
it's obvious in retrospect from personal
conversations almost everyone who taught
me was on the left there was no way to
know that from their teaching run from
their curriculum and what inspired me in
terms of how I teach and I think it's a
model for both history and the
humanities in general so I was taking a
course from a Marxist izing Princeton
historian of the 20th century who gave
us a great diversity of things to read
but among them some pieces of his own so
students knew where he was coming from
when he gave back the midterms
he said you
shamed me I gave you a lot of different
perspectives to read and you all told me
what you thought I wanted to hear so for
the final exam I am going to assign the
book I disagree with most about the 20th
century and I am not going to ask you to
critique it I am gonna ask you to
recreate its arguments with intellectual
empathy so that I know that you are
intimately familiar with points of view
other than my own
the text was Hayek's the Road to Serfdom
it completely changed my own
intellectual and moral life and
trajectory and as it happened I said to
myself I already knew I wanted to teach
that's how I want to teach I want my
students to understand other
perspectives empathetically
from within and then they can make their
judgments later on what is driving the
kind of shift from you know trying to
inculcate critical thinking to a sense
of indoctrination and this I say this is
we've had these conversations in other
contexts but when I went to undergrad
and grad school I started grad school in
the late 80s and by the mid 90s I was
done with it but I noticed even then a
shift from a kind of older model which I
identified with sixties revolts where
you would go to college and you would
have teachings you know there was a lot
of politics but it was all about let's
talk about stuff and even in my PhD
courses there was an older generation of
60 professors who were trained in the
sixties who wanted to argue about
everything and then there were people
who beat later who were like no the
arguments are done and now what we need
to do is go out there and we're doing
missionary work we're not we're not
engaging in free play or inquiry and
missionary work is the antithesis of my
critical education so real what what
what was going on there I mean and as
somebody who if I mean if you started in
68 your your of
yeah several generations before current
people coming out with PhDs but what was
the shift let's go back to the 70s to
set it in context in 1971 I co-founded
at Penn a college house that we
recruited students in every imaginable
context and we Stroke where you were
able to have did you have women at Penn
by them well yes and we were the first
college house to be co-ed with men and
women living on the same floor I mean
sit on that yeah all four classes right
quarter each half man half women run we
very consciously sought what to me is
real diversity we wanted kids from
Wharton we wanted poets we want the kids
very active politically we wanted kids
who've spent their days in laboratories
and we ended up for eight years with the
most extraordinary house we had the
first wave of gay liberation activists
at Penn
we had the Executive Board of Campus
Crusade for Christ and I'm guessing they
were the same person
they just didn't know again they didn't
know it
we had Maoist revolutionaries we had the
virtually underground college
Republicans we had the first wave of
really militant feminists on campus and
we had lots of people from the
leadership of the Catholic Newman Center
at a time when Penn was about 3% black
just inviting students to come to a
place where you could just be yourself
that's the way we presented ourselves
integrate your intellectual and
residential life cultural and
residential life and just be yourself
time when Penn was 3% black
we were 20% black absolutely
extraordinary and these kids argued all
the time they spent their life arguing
but they humanize their relationships
they learn to talk to each other they
identified their points of disagreement
I was there a Hayekian defender of free
market surrounded by majority of
students as the students were arguing
what were your faculty colleagues also
arguing yes so and then I mean so what
happened that we I mean the the picture
you're painting here is you know is
unimaginable essentially on most
campuses where you either you segregate
by ideology or you know in the you know
or this type of free space is not being
allowed it I think what happened at Penn
is typical of what happened in a lot of
places the ideology that came to
dominate all thinking about
undergraduate life is people are only
really comfortable with people like
themselves residentially so Penn built
the boys college house for black
students our students at Van Pelt
college house were under fierce pressure
to join that ironically Penn then was
sued by the NCAA
the n-double-a-cp for racial segregation
so they made it if you're interested in
black culture but originally it was for
for black students they built in East
Asia house they built a pre-med house
they built an arts house we used to have
people who were doing seminars on
artificial intelligence for the love of
it no credit
we had string quartets we had people who
are on the frontiers of endless fields
and now the university sense was well if
they live with people like themselves
they'll be more comfortable
we had a phenomenally wonderfully
integrated house racially University
decided against precisely what we had
demonstrated that no black students
should be encouraged to live with black
students and then the myth went they
would feel so strong that they
comfortably would move out into the
larger community what was the parallel
in the
intellectual because you know one of the
things that's interesting is that a lot
of the discussion about college and
university of higher education is always
about the student experience but I
personally I actually think the value of
college and universities is that there
are centers of knowledge production you
know both in the humanities or the
sciences or whatever and that the real
beating heart of the university is its
faculty life not its students life was
there that kind of siloing of knowledge
and of just you know discussion yes it
was quite extraordinary different for
faculty and a graduate students who were
fellows resident and fellows in the
house along with 180 undergraduates with
no police role we weren't sniffing out
drugs
I'm the present no we were there as
intellectual cultural human resources
every faculty member and graduate
student their tour de for the love of it
seminar every week all of which were
full undergraduates loved having that
and once a week we invited faculty
members to come in and talk about their
research African history brain structure
evolutionary psychology lutely
extraordinary and we would get a hundred
120 kids out of a hundred and eighty
thrilled that a faculty member was
coming down to talk about his or her
research that doesn't happen anymore and
it's it's very very hard how come is it
yet but what what happened I think the
infantilization of students played a
certain role in that for example every
one night a week every Wednesday night
our students could invite we dined
together four nights a week as a house
our students could invite any faculty
member they wished to get to know better
to come to the house for dinner a table
would be set up for people who wanted to
dine but what made that possible to a
certain extent was it was preceded by a
wine and sherry hour
now the University comes in and decides
that students are children there can be
no drinking between with faculty members
and students together and it used to
take about 20 minutes of disinhibition a
tour sherry oh right it's like a
fifth-grade dance boys on one side girls
on the other you know my fifth-grade
dancers didn't have much sherry birthday
at the scene and resident faculty used
to in the beginning would go to faculty
and say look the students are here
because they want to meet you and same
to the students and after a little
disinhibition from from wine and sherry
the conversations would become
extraordinary and most faculty were on a
first-name basis at our college right
which I assumed was contrary to the more
I mean a more conventional oh yeah I
would walk across campus and people go
hi professor X hi professor oh hey Alan
rut which I liked and these were
students who disagreed with me
passionately about politics the
undergraduate culture was overwhelmingly
on the Left we loved each other and we
talked you know you would grant any wish
there was at various points I'm sure
some of that collegiality bled over into
exploitation or difficulty and between
students and professors I mean I don't
think no I don't think so or no more so
than has happened now yes sir under no
stricter certainly no no and if anything
I think people may have even been more
careful there was a goldfish bowl
students used to joke that the last
person you'd have a relationship with
would be someone in the house because
everyone would be aware of it you know
now talk about the go back to your
second though what one of the ways in
which students have been infantile
abroad is the view that female students
lack agency and will be exploited by
predatory professors I met my wife in
Van Pelt college house
or in married till two years later so
this is like this is now turning into a
to catch a predator there you go exactly
you know you you've got so decades later
flash-forward when when fast forward
when the School of Arts and Sciences at
Penn past no intimacy between professors
and students I believe I was the only
faculty member to speak out against it
and I said look what everyone who knows
evolution those is a sorta t'v mating
you get two people in a lab interested
in the same protein they live in that
lab they talk science together all the
time it's the most natural way for
people to meet similar people colleges
or great centers of a sort of me faculty
looked at me as if I were out of my mind
it passed I was invited with my wife to
a dinner at the deans and I introduced
my wife to the Dean and I said rosemary
if if your policy had been in place this
loving marriage wouldn't exist our
beautiful children wouldn't exist she
turned red and said I'm not an anti
romantic but you have got to protect
women from predatory professors and my
wife said to her no your real problem
would have been how to protect
professors from predatory young women
such as I and my friends who found them
of great interest and these poor
innocents didn't know what to do with us
well you know you've written my last
invitation to advance they brought your
car around immediately what you've
written in reason and also in books like
the shadow university about this return
of in loco parentis and it is kind of
stunning that the 70s I mean the 60s
gets all the misty eyed remembrances but
it was
in the 70s where you know colleges
undergraduate - courses of study
worldwide and where people could make
more choices to make more choices living
living decisions and things like that
and that it looked like it was going to
be the new normal but in fact it was
it's been revealed to be a very brief
window I mean because colleges now
dictate courses of study much more than
I use how you live who you live with how
you talk where is that coming from I
think your question is the essential one
that has to be asked about what happened
to university education the same
generation that gave us the Free Speech
Movement gave a speech codes the same
generation that gave us mandatory Chapel
my last my freshman year at Princeton
was the last year of mandatory chat but
at least they advertised it right has
now given us mandatory sensitivity
training and diversity education before
you read a single book or participate in
religion debate but it's still there yes
but and the same kids who got themselves
treated as young adults and who smoke
pot openly on college lawns everywhere
now ban drinking beer in dormitories
it's a it's a generational swindle of
epic proportions and it happened the
first sign of it was cultural not
political it was the extraordinary
antipathy of faculty at a disco suddenly
students are not listening to the doors
and the stone jeff beck they're
listening to disco what the hell is that
and then my friend became for lip sync
and [ __ ] there but i think the
turning point in which university said
someone's got to save these kids from
themselves was the election of 1984
where a majority of college students
voted for Ronald Reagan and suddenly the
generation that expected to be guru
and leaders and mentors forever and as
long as people follow them give them
absolute freedom but now it was
perfectly obvious as these kids had
voted for Reagan that these kids had to
be saved from themselves and the first
thing to go was the freedom and the
adult status although participation had
gotten is also related to Ronald Reagan
because through his Department of
Transportation effectively raised the
national drinking age in that period
which must have had a huge effect I mean
you know now all we talk about on campus
is binge drinking and things like that
but I mean at least from the very early
days of the first universities in Europe
through the mid 80s drinking and college
were very heavily correlate yes if you
tell if you tell most European students
and faculty that it would be caused to
be fired from an American University if
you went drinking with your students
which I do by the way I do go drinking
with my students
Europeans are absolutely incredulous not
that I want their educational Rustom but
their students or adults right in terms
of how the university perceives and
treats them well thoroughly students
about the universe now I mean this
ongoing infantile ization this return of
in loco parentis was one of the Spurs to
you creating with Harvey silverglade
fire the foundation for individual
rights in education and talk a little
bit about how the activities of that
organization respond to kind of
incursions not just on free speech but
on due process for student life yes in
terms of free speech fire has never lost
the case where it's challenged a speech
code in federal court at a public
university and you're clear that I mean
you think speech codes are bad ideas of
private universities but they are
governed differently or they should be
governed differently than a public
university where because it's publicly
funded and supported it has to follow
the first amount the way well yeah I
mean
public universities must follow the
First Amendment you can't use a
governmental agency to silence people in
violation of the of the First Amendment
what the case is at private universities
fire has followed the following
principle that a private university is
bound by the promises it makes and the
invitation it makes to students to
attend there so if a university says we
are a marketplace of ideas if a
university says this is a place where
you can say anything think anything it's
got to hold to that but then can't come
in and impose a speech code if you go to
bring them young University you don't
awake one morning in your freshman year
and say oh my god they're Mormon if you
choose to go to a Benedictine seminary
it doesn't occur to you oh they got me
here under forge O'Lantern it's a
Catholic seminary run that's what it's
it's a voluntary Association organized
around certain beliefs and it openly
advertises but most of our universities
private promise free speech promise
legal equality and then deliver
selective suppression of speech yes and
it's based almost always viewpoint
specific it's always a viewpoint
specific the easiest way to think of it
is the critical word is offend right
that's that's what you can't you can't
offend me the first time that these
speech codes were taken literally and
let's say for the sake of argument some
feminist professor were brought up on
charges of having verbally harassed
evangelical Christian students by her
account of the church the faculty would
be out there on mass with free speech
academic freedom banners but that person
is never going to be brought up on
charges and knows it people of certain
politics and perspectives are never
going to be brought up on charges
so not only our speech codes of
violation of that atmosphere of freedom
and risk-taking that a university ought
to promote not discourage speech codes
are also instantaneously and by choice
the imposition of double standards and
unequal justice no you know I think when
I talk to people about specific fire
cases they're like oh that makes sense
you know that you push back against this
but then there's seems to be among
people who are not either conservative
or libertarian and conservatives I think
are often in this because of the
viewpoint dimension not the larger
principle of free expression but they
say yeah but you know what come on it
comes down to we're talking about frat
kids who are doing you know slave
auctions or saying the word [ __ ] or
putting on blackface what what are the
typical cases where somebody is having a
speech do those cases actually are
relatively rare but let's take them do
you think that a performance of The
Vagina Monologues for example would be
interrupted as sexual harassment and the
play banned if a group of feminists put
on on any college campus something that
you or I might consider male-bashing
run in a nanosecond we would know know
that's protected speech so you get
selective enforcement the other thing of
course is the best answer speech you
don't like is more speech and protest
when I was involved in bringing down
speech code at the University of
Pennsylvania but it was still operative
the university came and honored Andra
Serrano's piss Christ as a crucifix
immersed in the artists urine and gave
him an occasion for an honorary speech
exhibit of piss Christ loving this was
loving work of art that had ties to
public funding and it was in addition to
everything else it was publicly funded
yes and and was a flashpoint in the
cultural course yeah that's right but in
the culture war of the 80s and not exist
exactly so so a group of people from the
Newman Center and from evangelical
groups came to me and said this is a
terrible double standard they should
suppress this Andres Serrano event they
wouldn't let anyone else be insulted
like this except Christians and I said
why in the world would you want
censorship if I were you what I would do
is hold an event here's what the cross
means the university here's what it
means to us well it turned out to be the
largest and most significant religious
gathering in the history of the
University of Pennsylvania it reminded
me of when the American Nazi Party
wanted to march in Skokie which has a
very high percentage of Holocaust
survivors at the time and the city
fathers banned them ACLU took the city
fathers to court and the court obviously
found city fathers can to ban groups
they don't like from peacefully marching
so what happened the picture that went
forth to the world was as people more as
the American Nazi Party and their Serge
uniforms marching down the street you
see everyone along the sidewalk with
their backs turned in contempt freedom
is a wonderful medium run and if you
don't ban speech and expression you have
to deal with it and if you can't do that
at a universe
versity where on earth can you do it how
astonishing that you have greater
freedom to publish what you want in the
language in which you want to publish it
out there in civil society than you
would were you a campus magazine and I
guarantee you that reason published on a
campus would be defunded and that you'd
be up on harassment charges every other
week is it that we don't need as much
free speech and I'm not saying this is a
good thing but we don't need as much
free speech on campuses because it's
busting out all over the place despite
all attempts to quash it whether through
political speech code or you know
campaign finance or whatever it is I in
terms of college campuses I teach an
honor seminar on the history of
classical liberal thought John Stuart
Mill Spencer Bastia Hayek Mises etc and
students uniformly without exception
tell me afterwards they have no idea of
my own beliefs its analytic and
comparative students tell me it is the
first time they have ever read and in
many cases heard of Peter Bauer even if
there are students at Wharton you know
they've never heard of Hayek they've
never heard of Milton Friedman so it's
not clear that the bait is busting out
all over
well thank you Allan chorus for talking
with reason TV this has been great for
Reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie
you